foreign
[Applause]
yeah all right all right all right yeah
just when you thought New York couldn't
get any nastier it now smells like a
humid day inside Joy behar's MooMoo
Canadian wildfires are producing tons of
smoke all Landing here making it the
worst thing from that country since Seth
Rogen but as the trees burn another tree
speaks out yes human Elm John Kerry
commemorated the 79th anniversary of
D-Day by comparing it to the fight
against climate change
note to John it's okay to visit the
statues at Easter Island just don't turn
into one
he claims the climate change fight
requires the same level of innovation
and mobilization that was required to
fight the Nazis but today's threat comes
from all of us so if you don't recycle
and buy an EV well then you're the new
Hitler
uh he found that funny
plus he's the last guy I talked to about
the environment the guy threw away his
medals and that's littering meanwhile
East Coasters are suffering which makes
them smile nothing like human misery to
pave the way for a paragraph if this
smog keeps up churches will be closed
you'll only be allowed out for food and
pride parades
AOC says that this smoke out just shows
us how unprepared we are for the climate
crisis we must adapt Our Food Systems
energy grids infrastructure Health Care
blah blah blah barf because when the
government says adapt they mean seize
and Destroy but if she really cared
about too much CO2 in the air she'd shut
her gob
does she think this is the first forest
fire in the history of the world
well actually she might she has an
economics degree and still thinks
shutting down businesses creates new
jobs
she's not bright
five cows fart in Calcutta and she's
ready to send us back to the days of
horse and buggy
by the way aren't we teaching kids about
Smokey the Bear anymore
I mean that is if Smokey still
identifies as a bear
then there's human chinchilla Chuck
Schumer who claims that the smoke is a
warning that we have a lot of work to do
to reverse the destruction of climate
change okay but does that work include
teaching people not to throw a lit
cigarette out of a window of a car or
maybe douse that campfire when you're
done playing Davey Crockett
he add he adds quote we passed the
inflation reduction act to put us on
track to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions 50 by 2030 but we must do more
oh wait that's why you passed the
inflation reduction act I thought it was
supposed to stop a pound of Bologna from
costing more than a pound of lobster you
pound of crap
how about Squad pot pramila jayapal
quote imagine being a republican climate
change denier in Congress you see the
skies filled with smoke and you still
don't get that we need immediate action
to save our planet
well again imagine being a Democrat who
hasn't heard about the discovery of fire
imagine this lady in the Fourth of July
you light a Roman Candle you say it's
worse than 9 11.
and what's Canada's non-binary Bozo
doing
people across the country are being
affected we're seeing vulnerable people
at risk outdoor events canceled kids
having to be kept inside at recess
I can't help but think
my conversation with Liam yesterday to
conversations with my own kids the past
few years
have been challenging for kids
God's sake please stop thinking about
the kids
but at least Trudeau has a plan for
using the leftover soot
USA Today asks as candidate Burns smoke
makes U.S air unhealthy and Sky's Eerie
is climate change to blame well no USA
Today people burning your newspaper to
get a grill that is more likely the
cause
the fact is 90 of forest fires are
caused by humans campfires left
unattended discarded cigarettes
equipment malfunctions and the burning
of debris like when I set fire to those
old Love Letters from Larry Kudlow
it was hard to do did you know one in
four wildfires are actually caused by
arson and that includes Dana Perino
taking out ants with a magnifying glass
evil and finally according to their own
forestry data since 1990 the number of
forest fires in Canada has actually
declined which is not to say they aren't
aided by bad Forest management which
leads to lots of dry wood around ready
to burn the only bigger fire hazard is
killmead's Playboy collection
pervert
and you can think green activists for
that who reject actual Solutions logging
and other commercial practices would
tend to Forest Health out of
self-interest but they're getting phased
out and Canada is having problems with
fires on their public lands due to lack
of funds I guess they're too busy
spending money Prosecuting teachers for
misgendering students meanwhile all our
White House says is they want to restore
old growth in mature forests I guess
which explains this
bottom line more controlled Burns would
prevent future devastating wildfires I
say we start with a pallet of Jesse
Waters books
and I suggest
he's not the gov but he gets all our
love former New York Congressman Lee
Zelda
just like me injuries kept her from
competing in the Olympics I'll kick host
Charlie or no
he won
he wants sunburn from a scented candle
Fox News contributor Tom chalou
and she's easy on the eyes but murder on
the ears Fox News contributor captive
Tom you've been out and around the city
that's right what's it like to you what
have you been experiencing this it's
actually a pretty good day today yeah um
yesterday it was It was kind of eerie
but I did like the light people were
overreacting a little bit this does
happen in other states Molly Hemingway
made the observation that it happens in
other parts of the country a lot but
because this is New York and Washington
where all the journalists are they're
really covering this big yeah but I
loved your monologue I was gonna talk
about Smokey Bear and then you you I did
that gay slur
what happened to Smokey the Bear that's
the thing we haven't stressed fire
prevention do you remember he always
used to say only you can prevent forests
exactly and no one's disproved that yes
it's only you yes and you like you said
I like that statistic 90 is people who
who are being careless we could do this
with fire management and by educating
people to put out their fires a fire
management is a big thing controlled
Burns and some sometimes
environmentalists fight against these
controlled Burns that have if you do
them then you reduce the amount of uh
refuse and wood and dry stuff that's out
there and you're going to have fewer
forest fires but the environmentalists
fight it why because I think they really
they love this stuff they love anything
they can blame on climate change there
you go yeah you know climate change is
the new white guy
Charlie welcome to the show thank you
how do you say your last name Arnold
Arnold I said Arno I like it it sounds
very European exactly exactly I said on
the five Charlie arnode Arno Arnold what
do you make of the media response to all
this I think it's ridiculous I think
it's funny that Smokey the Bear is
better at his job than John Kerry or AOC
yes uh but it's crazy because John Kerry
I mean he's the climate Czar yet he
knows nothing about the climate remember
2009 it was I think he said that there
was going to be no ice left in the
Arctic by 2014 well now here we are in
AOC same thing knows absolutely nothing
about the climate wants to spend 94
trillion dollars on her new green plan
uh when really there is no evidence it
will do anything to help the climate
it's nothing but a money grab and
fundraising effort to help her and her
fellow Democrat cronies who are all
super excited right now by the way to
see all of us wearing masks again yeah
that's true that's true and also when
you make these uh uh apocalyptic uh uh
predictions or whatever you don't have
to provide Solutions like you could just
ask for the money but it's untethered to
any kind of direct action then you just
move on to the next Panic Lee if you
were governor and you should have been
hoco is of course she's doing the same
thing that she always does she makes a
pronouncement and then she goes back
into the house and orders sushi
she banned gas stoves yes she banned the
sale of gas cars after 2035 they won't
approve any new pipelines they won't
allow the extraction of natural gas
they're running out of dumbass ideas
the photo by the way if you if you look
closely it's amazing the similarity
between New York City and uh Hunter
Biden's Crackdown yes have you noticed
that yeah it is true it is true we uh we
have an issue where we have to be smart
on this we're getting gas lit they're
talking about what's happening with this
climate crisis
and they want to push further I don't
know how much more damage they could do
in New York but everything anyone's
watching what's happening with New York
Democrats they want to bring this to a
city and state near you so pay attention
Kat you're an expert in Forest
management I've
been to one yes you've been to a forest
yes I have managed to get to a forest a
thousand percent yes where do you see uh
where do you see the the story here
we've talked about failure in government
and the media hyping out some other kind
of catastrophe yeah I know I agree with
it you said which was Molly's Point as
well of the media loves it because we
can make it about us like it wasn't that
the smoke went far so the smoke went to
the media and like for me I get it like
for me it's like baby's first forest
fire like yeah I've never been around
one before yeah uh but a lot of people
are around them all the time and we're
just like that's like oh yeah that's bad
but we don't talk about it this much
because we can't talk about ourselves
right uh and they're really the
solutions ironically with capitalism
comes Innovation which comes to
solutions to problems uh what a lot of
these people don't want to recognize
that they just want to bring more
attention and of course true Justin
Trudeau is uh one of the those climate
guys yeah so but this still happened
right yeah exactly could you imagine if
this happened here and there was a
Republican president and Justin you
think Justin Trudeau wouldn't bring that
up yeah of course like of course the
world's on fire Republicans the
president yes
on his watch yeah on his watch as they
said yes
yeah where's your black face now huh
more like red face see what I did there
I changed the color you can bet to your
point that there's gonna be all these
New York writers writing about this
what we did when the sky went orange oh
yeah forever that'll be the headline
even the amount of people who posted it
on their Instagram story like do you not
think I cannot get a better picture by
Googling it myself exactly it's like
when they do the picture of what do they
call the full moon or the oh the the wet
moon it's like it's just a picture of a
moon or if you go to the zoo when they
post like this blurry picture of a
gorilla like I can just Google gorilla
yes
sponsored videos
we can we can listen to the music on our
own yeah I think we should be able to
get rid of all zoos and just replace
them with Google hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else